welcome back to Facebook and uncensored
it doesn't really feel like the world is
making much progress right now with
covid pandemic kill Millions left many
more of us locked up and miserable for
months on end the Earth it's apparent in
the process of sizzling us all to death
through climate change Russia's invasion
of Ukraine brought War to Europe and
nudged the world closer to nuclear
Armageddon all of this while inflation
is soaring massive economies face
recession and children and start living
with their parents until they're my age
well if you believe what you read then
this broken and battered world of ours
has ever been more racist sexist or
divided who better to put all this into
proper context though than my next
because Professor Stephen Pinker who
coined the term progress of phobia
Professor great to see you
thank you I've wanted to have you on
this program for a long time because I
actually quoted from you from your
brilliant book Enlightenment now uh in
my own book uh called wake up last year
and it was like a Clarion call to the
world to wake up and one of the reasons
was as you rightly observed actually all
things considered there's ever been a
better time to be alive now do you still
believe that today
well I don't know about uh this very
moment or this very day but certainly it
we're better off now than we were 100
years ago or 200 years ago there are
always ups and downs so it's uh it's
always dangerous to say this today this
very day is the best day in history
probably isn't we've got an invasion in
uh Ukraine that's turning back the clock
we're still not over the effects of
covet but you know on average looking at
the overall trend yeah we're better off
than we were 50 years ago or 100 years
ago or 200 years ago and a thousand
years ago a lot of young people uh
suffer from anxiety far more than has
ever been recorded before and I I
believe one of the reasons is the
constant dopamine exposure they get to
negative imagery whether it's the war in
Ukraine the pandemic whatever it may be
that this sensory overload has created
an atmosphere in there in their heads
that things have never been worse than
they are now what's the best way to
realign young impressionable Minds about
why in your estimation the trend is
pretty good
yeah it's you know it's not just the the
dopamine hit of the image every 20
seconds it's also the overall message a
lot of young people are being told that
the species is going to go extinct if
not from
um climate change than from artificial
intelligence or uh or or Civil War
um so I think the news just has to put
things in perspective because the
journalism is a non-random sample of the
worst things happening everywhere on on
Earth that's just kind of what news is
uh the slow trends that creep up a few
percentage points a year like the
reduction of extreme poverty increased
access to electricity and clean water uh
Rising literacy declining child
mortality declining maternal mortality
all of these are never never burst on
the scene on Thursday and so you never
see a headline but they transform the
world because these changes uh compound
also there are things that good things
that consist of things that don't happen
like just a few years ago we were
obsessed with terrorism it felt like
there was constantly a terrorist attack
now uh they are uh uh far less frequent
but you never see a headline it's been
several years since a European city has
uh shot up or or blown up by terrorists
so the news gives a non-random sample of
the uh generally of what's going wrong
and so more of a focus on long-term
trends on putting particular events in
statistical context so that a school
shooting or a police shooting doesn't
mean that you are in danger if you uh
step out onto the pavement just so that
people can put the anecdotes and images
in context of which way the world was
going also when it comes to to things
that are creeping up on us like climate
change
um some perspective as to uh what is
again what is what is going right what
are the changing estimates of the
probabilities of the different scenarios
a lot of young people can't get out of
our head their heads the worst case
scenario which seemed disconcertingly
too likely a few years ago but now the
estimates are that the worst case
scenario is is much less likely that's
the kind of news that needs to be
highlighted and the people who are
counseling young people I have I have
seen this even at my own institution uh
dealing with say climate anxiety they
say well yes it's such a serious problem
that is very good that you're anxious
well no your anxiety is not going to
save the planet your actions are going
to save the planet if you develop clean
meat or clean energy or better policies
but simply being miserable is not going
to help the planet and unfortunately a
lot of our counselors are conveying
exactly the wrong message well funny
enough there was a report only last week
about uh actually the the incidence of
depression and anxiety amongst young
people and it established really quite
clearly that if you could distract those
people by making them think about
positive things or other stuff than the
stuff the negative things they were
dwelling on actually had a a
self-fulfilling prophecy they ended up
feeling more positive and less depressed
I I don't doubt it and it the the
reaction you get to that kind of
suggestion is well the world is burning
and uh things are getting worse you
don't want to instill complacency you
don't want people to think oh everything
is great I can lie back and relax well
of course that isn't the message the
message is things get better only if you
make them better but you've got to have
the confidence that trying to make the
world a better place might now get now
and again work and the message that
we've been sending is nothing is working
despite ever
efforts to make the world a better place
things are getting worse and worse until
the species goes extinct
and so the message can't just be let's
distract ourselves with you know with
with kittens and and heartwarming
stories of you know policemen who buys
groceries for a welfare mom but that
that's not what constructive journalism
would consist of it would consist of uh
the growth of Renewables the new
technologies on the horizon that might
deliver abundant clean energy the uh of
the countries that have eliminated
diseases the new vaccines for diseases
like malaria and and
other diseases the uh Rising literacy
rates be decline of coal uh there's lots
of actually substantive positive
developments that are simply not
reported except for a handful of sites
that specialize in it that I think more
people should subscribe to for their
mental health and for no other reason
but also to involve the the
countering the danger of complacency is
the danger of fatalism doesn't matter
what we do but what's going to help me
as well enjoy
yeah I totally agree
um one of the other scourges of modern
life other than this constant obsession
with all things negative is the attack
on Free Speech you went to Harvard
University and it was just ranked the
worst school for free speech in the
United States by the foundation for
individual rights and expression they
got zero points out of a hundred how do
you feel is it a Harvard alumni that it
is effectively become a walking talking
enemy of free speech
yes well I'm not uh
I'm not an undergraduate alumnus but I
am a professor so I'm right there in the
thick of things
and together with some colleagues we
have formed the Council on academic
freedom at Harvard in order to push back
and in fact those rankings were even a
little bit convenient because when we
met with the president last week and
when we're meeting with the dean
tomorrow first thing we're gonna do uh
and the first that we did was to say hey
we came in in last place in 248
universities don't you think we should
do something in your purpose uh and I
hope we will why why are University
campuses All Over America and it's
happening in the UK why are they not
embracing
Free Speech why are they so insistent on
trying to suppress people's views D
platform people's views they don't like
have we got to this place
I know I would almost split the question
free speech is a deeply weird concept as
far as the human mind is concerned it's
very unintuitive what's obvious is that
people who disagree with me are
spreading dangerous falsehoods and must
be suppressed for the greater good
that's just a natural way we think the
idea of free speech going back to a
little bit the ancient Greeks and John
Stuart Mill and the Free Speech movement
that constantly has to be renewed people
need to be reminded of why they should
ignore their instincts to suppress
voices they disagree with step back and
realize hey it feels like I'm right but
you know I'm not infallible I'm not
omniscient a lot of people in the past
thought they were right they turned out
to be wrong a better system is one where
everyone gets to voice their opinions
and we get to argue about who's right
who's wrong well I do think uh Professor
Pinkerton as long as people like you are
still at Harvard there's a hope there's
a tiny fragment of Hope for them when it
comes to defending Free Speech
it's great to have you on the programs
I wish you luck and getting them all on
side it's great to have you on Facebook
and I said so thank you so much indeed
for joining me